I want to first say that I'm really
jealous of Jonathan France because he
teaches the opening lectures another day
of the week which I don't get to teach
which I love kind of teaching openings
and I have a lot of like cool tricks so
I thought today I would show you a bunch
of games in I'm a similar opening and
then if you don't play the opening you
can kind of use it as inspiration to
maybe try something new but I think this
is a common opening if you're an e4
player or if you're a Sicilian player so
first I want to get a poll of how many
four players are here are there in this
room everyone well most people how many
people don't play you for 10 less okay
so two people oh okay maybe next week
will call will cover the French and how
to beat it quickly how many people play
the Sicilian against efore sometimes no
one else okay today we're going to look
at what's known as the Grand Prix
Sicilian or the closest queueing
basically the position starting after E
for C 593 and if the opening doesn't
apply to you then hopefully you can at
least take away some like cool attacking
ideas from early on and this was an
opening I kind of discovered around when
I was 2000 and I studied a lot of it in
chess base got a book on it began
playing it like a lot online and
basically from the time I was 2,000
until I was 20 200 I never liked slogan
I never plateaued I think partly because
of this opening I trapped a lot of
people in and this opening there's so
many traps which hopefully we'll see a
good number of today so the first game
or games I wanna start with happens
after black plays g6 and I actually
played a tournament at the club not too
long ago
it was the
whatever Saturday night special I know
if any of you played but it's like one
big open tournament so in the first
round the matchups are there's a pretty
big rating disparity between the
matchups first time I was playing
someone maybe a lot of thousand points
below me and we got to this position and
in this position I like to play a move
which maybe isn't the most common can
west f4 is probably the most common move
if you're a Grand Prix player if you
like to play close Sicilian that would
be g3 it was actually a third move here
which I discovered like less than a year
ago and I thought it was a highly
venomous especially for players who
might be expecting at for g3 it's just
another alternative for whites probably
one of the more aggressive alternatives
which is d4 and what this does is trying
question blacks set up as quickly as
possible so what my opponent did at the
Saturday night tournament is he played
Bishop to g7 I should note that if black
takes white can take and the main line
usually goes something like Knight f6
Bishop b5 and black has to be very
careful we might actually see a game in
this later but for now we'll look at
after d4 Bishop g7 here I take the pawn
and black is temporarily sacrificing the
pawn on c5 in hopes of winning it back
and hear my opponent played a queen to
c7 the other move is queen a5 and I'll
have to explain that beam these moves
can transpose into each other so first
let me show you what I did after Queen
c7 I played Knight to d5 my opponent
took the pawn now I played a very sneaky
move here and this move might be a
little bit strange you can say
first might not seem like it has a
purpose but it's very very dangerous
move as Bishop to b2 and the threat is a
little bit hidden if if black isn't
careful and what my opponent did
probably a the losing move
she played Knight to f6 might actually
be losing for a few reasons
but like to move in this position what
would you guys do anyone yes sergeant
this would be for very good and that's
what I did and the problem for black is
the queen is very limited on squares and
follow-up question what happens after
Queen c6 yes this should be five very
good
it might look tempting to take the pawn
in seven but this should be five
actually traps the Queen the Queen has
nowhere to go
White's pieces coordinate amazingly and
the problem for black is that if the
Queen takes the bishop or queenie sixers
makes and seven possibilities and white
light would just win a queen and i think
there's been a few games that have ended
here after Bishop e5 and black just
gives up losing the Queen so but this
was kind of a nice game to know if your
opponent just unknowingly walks into
this now let me show you another similar
line that can happen a same position in
this position black plays Queen to a5
and I should note that the players in
this game I can't really pronounce
because there's way too many consonants
in a work and a row of this game but
Michael against Rainier and a similar
type game where light wings very quickly
due to exploiting the black Queen so
let's see if anyone can actually figure
out the move here we didn't look at
Queen a5 before but what would you guys
play in this position
and knowing what we just saw
yeah this should be - and basically you
just want to transpose after Queen takes
e5 last move is Nike 595 looks a little
bit weird but it's just the same
position before with the same threat of
Bishop b4 Queen c6 Bishop e5 and it's
such an easy threat to miss so before we
go any further I should point out the
best move for black in this position is
not very obvious the best move is Knight
to a6 simply defending c7 but it's a
little unusual to put the nylon e6 and
if you wanted to continue here from
White's I can just simply develop Knight
f3 there's actually a cool idea here
after black plays a 6 well I can play
Bishop to c3 of an intermediate move and
basically forcing the exchange of the
bishops and after black is pretty much
obliged to take an afternoon I take
white hasn't won anything but the
weaknesses in blacks position are pretty
horrific it's usually a bad idea has
played g6 and e6 too early and give away
your dark for Bishop and White has ideas
of e5 and 94 so does that make sense to
people if we go back that's really the
best case scenario for black
this is 96 move in the game black played
very greedy this should take b2 just
going for material and as we'll see this
gets punished pretty severely
white played rook to d1 Bishop retreats
Knight f3 I think from this point until
the end of the game every move is a
threat from lights and boxes has a very
juicy fish have been clean very easy to
exploit in the center of the board so
Bishop c7 was played now the problem
with Bishop e7 is it's a kind of
long-term target and the Queen is tied
down to defend the bishop and all white
needs to do is try and just remove the
Queen from divine vision so
very nice move rook to b5 Queen c6 like
just keeps attacking clean 94 Queen b6
anyone want to find the final move for
white bishop sorry bishop before is yeah
probably winning a white played Bishop
f4 in both moves there's probably
several winning moves here but I thought
this was a really funny position my
white just has so many pieces developed
and the only pieces developed for black
are are the ones which are the targets
so I will say that it's very easy to
kind of stumble into this this black
kind of just played natural moves and
white light was prepared with kind of
some venomous counterplay so any
questions about this so I would keep in
mind and actually have a recommendation
that okay this was a different move
order but if you know your opponent
plays g6 against close Sicilian and you
want to surprise them then you might
want to consider playing v4 try and
catch them off guard and I will say if I
know my opponent plays this line is
black I will usually go for d4 so let's
switch gears let's look at a maybe a
different black response against 93 I
want to show you probably the most
common a common way that black will lose
in the Grand Prix and the game I'm about
to show you I basically play the same
game at least four or five times and
online blitz and maybe once or twice in
tournaments and it's a very nice
illustration of how lack just plays
natural moves and then just gets
overwhelmed with with attack and will
see more of a kind of classic example of
Grand Prix so E for c5 Knight c3 black
plays d6 most players will play d6 here
because most players either play neither
for Dragon
pretty common now before we go any
further I should note that like the most
common piece placement for white in
Grand Prix is pawn on f4 92 f3 Bishop c4
d3 and castle and we'll see why play is
basically all these moves consecutively
so F 4 X 3 which is e4 Castle d3 and we
get to this position and here there's
some kind of interesting idea which if
you play this opening you kind of have
to know that after 97 Black has a threat
in the position so what does black
wanted to do after the night g7 yeah
Arjun but I wants to play d5 very good
so then the next question is how does
like stop it
you know I'll play f5 f5 is very
thematic for this position but isn't
played so soon I think I'll show you
guys because the move to stop d5 is not
that obvious that's kind of a tricky and
it's also a multi-purpose move move is
queenie one it's simply taking advantage
of the x-ray vision where if black does
play d5 the e-file opens and the night
is 10 and white we just went up on so
not only does queenie one like
temporarily stopped d5 but it also plans
to maneuver the Queen to the king side
and this is an incredibly common idea in
the Grand Prix where when you're a spawn
is moved so early you want to maneuver
your queen usually from e1 to h4 g3
basic Oh black castles and in this
position very key move from Lex and when
I first learned this move I was very
skeptical of it because it looks like
maybe a little over-aggressive bit too
risky and then the more I looked into it
the more I realized that this is
actually a very dangerous move for black
to do it and the move as he said earlier
is SS pawn sacrifice and usually my
style is more like conservative I don't
like sacrificing material if I don't
have to usually I'm the one who likes
grab material and then hold on and
actually the first time I was exposed to
this f5 idea it was on the black side I
lost a very quick game as black and
after that I actually started playing
this openings like so here black can
take the pawn on mainly two different
ways but I can take with a pawn G pawn
or black and go for d5 so I want you
guys to imagine that you're in this
situation is black and you can choose
between these three moves you can take G
take f5
you take f5 or d5 I'm curious what you
guys would play so I'll give you maybe a
minute to think and then we'll take a
poll now I'll tell you what's good and
what's bad
all right um didn't give you guys too
much time but might have to go with your
intuition so how many people would take
played you take out five anyone no okay
who would play you take out five be some
number of people about half of you uh
who would play d5 one to two people
anyone would do something else only gave
you three options so hopefully not these
are the three most common moves I will
say the worst move is you take out five
it's probably the most played move it
looks like the most natural you kind of
take a towards your keen side so you
trying to spend more but we'll see that
why this is bad the best moves are
either d5 or GTA v gta5 is very brave I
will say I think there was a game not
too long ago that Leslie so played as
black in this in the same position and
he played you take i-5 and I believe it
was protesting and I believe it was a
draw but white had good amount of
initiative the whole game probably the
move I would prefer d5 where you're
aiming to do and this applies to kind of
the principle that we discussed in the
other lecture where if your opponent is
playing on a flank or on the side it's
usually best responded Center in this
case kind of no difference you gain
temple on the bishop and the main line
here would be white usually plays Bishop
to b3 and then black has an interesting
idea
I can play c4 here I'm really taking
over the initiative force white to take
and then black can play d4 and I will
say that this is a very complex position
and we could spend our to talking about
it it's important if you play this as
White's you should know that the main
idea here which is f6 and this might be
a little beyond my understanding too but
as far as I know after Bishop they got
six like completely five very very
complex Knight Bishop are hanging but
the idea is that if the bishop moves or
if pawn is captured on e5 then I can
move to e4 and that white still goes for
for some attack on the King side so it's
important if you play an opening you
want to be prepared for like all
responses that your opponent could do
but okay let's go back let's see why
II take f5 is so bad honestly it doesn't
look too bad at first and White's next
move maybe doesn't look that impressive
Queen h4 the problem that arises for
black in this position is what to do
next and it's not that obvious how black
should continue there's no obvious
targets that can attack and I will say
that most people play Knight d4 or nike5
these are the two most common moves I
should note that if Bishop e6 this loses
tactically to take taken Knight g5 too
many Forks and checkmate expects so
let's look at move I have 95 white to
move how do you continue your attack
very nice move here for whites
yeah this should be five actually
surprisingly simple too but the idea is
you just want to overwhelm this 97 the
problem for black f6 is not possible
not legal and white will inevitably
continue with 95 so the the game I have
prepare there's actually two games which
ended in the same technique and as well
so it's rook e8 and I take e5 first just
kind of simplifying and then 95 and it's
very annoying for black to defend 97 as
we can see if black plays and move like
Bishop f8 it's just made into Knight f6
and techniques what happened in both of
these games after King f8 only other way
to defend the Knights then Queen pig h7
and blacks position just falls apart
really quickly and notice like all of
blacks pieces are just I'm terrible
squares Queen b6 night 87 or take e7 now
Bishop h6 what idea that after they
should take aged six there are D queen
h8 names so interestingly enough both
games that reach this position had Queen
f6 played now White's a move made in one
yeah Queen h8 me it's kind of a nice
name and the games were Kirsch stern
2004 and heading house mangle 1995 I
will say that there's a lot of other
games which ended in a similar manner
and if we actually go back and see this
position after rook e8 there's been 27
games in the database likes won every
single every single one so usually if
there's so many games played and white
wins every single one it's an opening to
at least take a look at odds are more
people will might walk into the same
thing
just make sure if you reach this
position that you win is white that'd be
embarrassing to be the only player who
ever loses so any questions about this
line there were some kind of opening
nuances but if you remember this f5
sacrifice at least in this position then
White's play flows very nicely okay
we'll move on I didn't want to like just
include all my games in this database
but this is the only game I included for
me since I played this opening many
times and this was probably one of my
best wins with uh playing this opening
and the doc story is a little bit
interesting I don't know if any of you
have played US Open before no it rotates
cities every year
nothing it's been in st. Louis recently
that's right and then I got moved to
like Florida or something yeah anyway I
played US Open a few years ago in
Phoenix and it was one of my worst
tournaments ever like I was struggling
to beat like players five six hundred
points below me and I was going to
withdraw before the last round but I
didn't withdraw because at US Open and
also some other tournaments they have
what's called mixed doubles anyone know
about this mixed doubles where a a guy
and a girl can team up and compete for
kind of a team prize and I had a mixed
doubles partner who was doing really
really well
and I actually got the partner by just
like asking random girls before the
tournament started if they wanted to be
my partner I was lucky enough to pick
one who ended up doing well and we were
in contention for mixed doubles price
and going for last round if I won my
game there would be a good chance that
we would each get some money for the
price so I was basically in a must-win
situation going into this game despite
the fact that I was having a pretty poor
tournament individually and last round I
was playing Vanessa West which is
actually a really good pairing because
she also was competing for mixels prize
and she's pretty well-known person I
think she works for us chefs does a lot
of good writing but this game I managed
to get the better of her and as we'll
see it was again Knight c3 Sicilian now
she played a another very common move
here in Knight to c6 and I will say that
I could if I wanted to go for the Grand
Prix and play at four and aim for kind
of a similar setup as what we saw before
where if g6 9 f3
this should g7 it would be very similar
to the previous example but usually when
people play 96 I like to play well
lesser common move and you'll notice a
lot this a lot especially with my
opening choices I usually go for lesser
common lines which the opponent might
not be so familiar with
I like surprise weapons so in this case
I played the ship to d5 you play this
kind left ok it's a fun line sure
so most people as black like they know
nice d4 is a main move but they don't
know too much beyond that and that's
very dangerous if you're playing this is
black you should know 94 and you should
know at least some ideas after that the
point of this should be 5 white just
simply wants to take on c6 double the
black pawns and then go for the kind of
same grand-prix set up so I will say
that is factly g6 I would take take f4
and then basically go for a similar
attack what we saw before with Queen e1
Queen h4 so let's focus on 94 94 looks
good improve the Knights and attack the
bishop I play back it looks like white
loses a tempo moving the Bishop to b5
and then back to C for one of the points
is that because of island e4 because the
light is committed there because the
knight is committed to d4 like to kind
of take advantage of this later on in
the game time
and we'll see that so e 6 was played 92
now I already have ideas and maybe
trading off blacks only developes and
essentially I want a castle as quickly
as possible and then open up the center
so she plays - tricks I castle
I should note all of this is opening
preparation so far all of this I'd seen
before and she kind of walked right into
my opening preparation she played a move
here or after she played it I was uh my
eyes kind of lit up because I knew that
she was about to fall into a very nice
trap and move she played looks very
natural at first 55 aiming to be very
aggressive in the center it makes a lot
of sense the problem with this move is
that there's a kind of hidden tactic and
this was actually I think based on
computer preparation where a flight
isn't familiar with it it's very very
hard to find kind of by yourself but
find you'd kind of the computer
recommendation here so I take take I'll
give you guys a shot to try and find the
move here for whites pretty surprising
move and after I played this move she
spent at least like 15-20 minutes so
like to move so yeah you kind of want to
look for sacrifices here that's some one
of them the main theme is that because
the Black team is in the center you can
afford to sacrifice okay I think I'll go
ahead and show it because it's really
not easy to come up with and even if I
show you next few moves it's still hard
to understand still takes like deeper
level of understanding so the first
movement might take d5 sacrificing a
night I take t5 I take on d4 so this was
pretty forced now I'm down a full piece
for fun but what happens next is
somewhat surprising I have this move
Queen h5 and the problem arises for
black that there's targets which are
actually somewhat difficult to defend
and yes white sacrifice but white is
pretty much guaranteed to win back the
piece and then get a better position I
think the best black in you here is get
some worse endgame down upon so the
amazing thing about this is in this
position looks like black and play
Bishop e6 just defend everything look
safe but now very simple move rook e1
and there's just too much pressure
there's too many pins the bishop is
pinned and upon his Kings meaning both
the bishop and the knight are hanging so
if we go back this position not too many
other options black can play I think one
option is to play 97 which you didn't
play and then like it's enough
compensation I think the other option
here is to play g5 block the Queen from
attacking life I'm pretty sure it's just
again too much conversation probably a
move like d3 or rook e1 or combination
those should should be enough to give
white some advantage so I should note
that after I played Queen H I've I had
not lost any time on my clock because I
had seen this position before I expect
actually saw this position for the first
time about three to four years before I
played this game and this was actually
my first time getting this position in
game and she used probably about 45
minutes to an hour after she played
Bishop e6
and the issue after review on its when
you're black you're searching for
resources which just aren't there so she
tried this moved here Knight to f4 which
I had actually never seen before so this
was my first time I had to kind of sit
down think and figure out what to do
I knew the computer evaluation I knew I
was at least a little bit better but the
question is what you do as white your
gala piece or Queens attacked what's the
best move kind left clean be 527 and I
take you six Oh
so rook take you six night take you six
and this should take oh wait waiver look
take you six take take that's possible I
don't know about this lady Queenie seven
there are some issues with back rank
mates I'm sure I considered that during
the game there's actually a more forcing
approach here for what there should be
five fragrance black has no other way to
really get out of check other than
Keeney seven now the move back wants to
play seven and here it's kind of just
simple fork when the knight f6 take and
it was nice to get just yeah aha
yeah I'm sure I considered Queen C 5
yeah the Queen b6 yeah I was nice to get
like such a good position from opening
with very little efforts you want allies
25 or okay so here one my piece back up
up on the game isn't over though and one
thing I will say it's actually still one
of my biggest weaknesses is the ability
to convert winning positions I don't
know if anyone else struggles with this
too sometimes it's more psychological
sometimes when you get in a winning
position you get more relaxed you maybe
get lazier and that's very dangerous and
here maybe there's more pressure on me I
don't know but I force myself to really
stay involved with the game and really
figure out the best sequence of play
after this point and after king f7 I
kind of hunkered down I thought for
maybe ten minutes and then probably
found the most decisive way to finish
things off here so anyone have any kind
of guesses of what white smooth white
White's next move would be Arden the
Henry's are stretched yeah I heard
something someone said something so
rookie six it's one of these like in two
of them moves you can like quickly in
the Blitz game long game I calculated
like pretty far and I will say when I
played rook taking six I didn't see a
force swing if I saw a lot of kind of
factors in the position said that there
would be more than that compensation and
the fact that really giving black no
choice
black ops to take and the point is after
Queenie for the Kings kind of awkwardly
placed if the King moves back to f7
techniques in to clean d5 Bishop takes
e4
so the king is forced to move to v6 it's
it's usually pretty sad when you're only
developed pieces your team and I made
sure not to let the King go back I take
on v7 just cut the King off and I'm not
going to show you guys the full game
because it actually went a bit longer
but I will show you and so like the
decisive moments Queen CAS attempting to
trade Queens of course when your clones
King is developed you don't want to
trade me and I just move back king c5
woods played it's kind of a surprising
move I kind of taken aback by this move
because it's developing the King even
further but it's kind of funny because
like what else does black do here
nothing else can really get out and I'm
threatening to take on d4 and the queen
is tied down to defending the rook so
king c5 is really the only way to the
handy for so add a bit more of a think
here and then found move Bishop to d7
and what this does is sort of simplify
so after Queen take I wind bat material
the count I'm up to pawns still have an
attack against the King and then wasn't
long before light winds I wanted to play
b4 but but maybe later
yeah I just figured like wind material
and then don't take any unnecessary
risks I'm sure there's lots of ways to
win with the King on c5 though so yeah
we tied for like third place and I think
one like conjured ax to each so nice way
to finish off kind of a bad tournament
and I would recommend like if you're
ever having a bad tournament
try not to withdraw I try and finish it
off because if you have a bad tournament
but you win the last round sometimes
it's a bit more uplifting anyone heard
of how you found hopefully everyone the
highest rated female player in the world
um she also played this opening which I
didn't realize like other top players go
for this line but um this was actually a
blitz game and she beat Kremmling in a
very nice trap where it's another
example if black isn't careful in the
opening or doesn't know the preparation
well enough I can easily walk into
something unknowingly so how you find is
lights applying the same line again Nike
for Bishop c4 and this time black does
something like very intuitive the fact
that the knight is I'm d4 might incline
black to play g6 and Bishop g7 probably
the most common approach for black here
so that's what Kremmling does unite of
three my personal preference is 92 and
this line I don't think it makes a
difference because white ends up taking
on d4 which happens and this was
actually a line I've studied in the past
and I've had a few games in myself white
actually has a surprising move here and
it's not to move the knight I'll let you
guys try and think think of a move which
isn't a knight move just still kind of
good yeah okay yeah clean up great very
good
Intermezzo developing the Queen making a
threat then later light will choose
where to place a knight so now black has
to deal with the maid in one threat and
what I found really interesting in this
position is that black doesn't have too
many options and actually the best move
in this position is not really the most
obvious move the best move is 96 and if
you're playing against someone who
doesn't know this line odds are they
won't play Knight h6 the common or most
common move I've ran into is e six which
is actually a mistake and a six walks
into kind of a very nice line which
which will see the problem of e-cigs and
this is kind of applies to any position
as you want to
identify what changes in a position
after opponent makes a move
so what squared is C six weekend I heard
a few squares but the right square is d6
nothing controlling d6 and this allows
light to play aggressively with the
ninth the best move here 95
I will say that if if not h6 is played
the best move would be knighted by e6 a
will get punished as we'll see 95 now
black has issues white is kind of
seizing the initiative 96 to the threat
I think the most common move here and
most natural move which was played is d6
clustered this is the game yes and how
you find like really well this game and
she played a really nice move here which
pretty sure is still opening preparation
so I'll ask you guys how do you continue
your initiative how do you continue
generating threats Queen g3 is one move
for sure to attack upon in b6 the other
move of which how you found played I'm
not sure if there's a huge difference
but probably the move she played is
slightly better it's clean a3
let's same idea going after d6 pawn and
not the easiest pawn to defend the
bishop is already kind of committed to
g7 and if the this shift retreats to f8
then d4 is lost there is actually a line
here where if black plays d5 going for
the double attack White has an
intermezzo they should be 5 so if we
look at this position it's maybe not
entirely clear with black it's supposed
to do now kremling probably played the
best move and the best move is really
really awkward to play Keeney 7
it feels wrong to play this move but I
mean other options aren't really good
another move which black and try is
Bishop to e5 I actually had one game a
maybe a few online games actually in
this position and I was fortunate enough
to already have a computer opening
preparation from the past and the
computer recommendation here is really
nice to see three trying to take on v4
after black takes white plays d4 and
it's just overwhelming White's develops
chasing away the bishop winning d6 pawn
good position for white so so let's look
at King seven and it still took work for
how you found to win because black is
defending the d6 pawn and it's uh it's
not over white right away but the
lasting problem for black is that the
King never really got to safety and as
you'll notice the King just stays in the
center and eventually white is able to
exploit it so c3 tick tick which is
probably a beneficial trade for white to
open the the D file into D pawn sighs
kind of an unusual position but there's
a lot of nice traditional factors for
whites mainly the d5 square very weak
the fact that the knight can jump there
very soon also the d6 pawn is a
backwards pawn on the half-open file so
Bishop e6 Queen b3 tacking b7 there's a
d5 and this was actually very important
for white to have keep control over d5
and after Bishop takes d5 not to take
back with the pawn but to take back with
the Queen in order for d5 to be a weak
slur White has to keep a piece there not
a pot if she were to take with pawn then
it would be harder for light to break
through
I deal with taken with the Queen is
eventually the Queen will move away and
the knight will get to be five so clean
T six again the rule is if your
opponent's king is less safe
don't take means no matter on the
material situation so Queen d3h six very
ugly moves to play I don't know I know
there's anything better maybe Bishop g5
was annoying for black problem is now
like it's uh even more time to carry
through with idea night before
Queenie 895 think black resigns blockers
I'm here because there's nowhere good
for the kingdom of what there's four
possibilities if King f8 or key e6
there's Knights c7 f king g7 there's 96
if King d8 probably still 96 and the
defining so I really like this game
because it was really nice opening
corporation but also a nice way of
converting the position which was
achieved from opening so any questions
about this no hopefully you guys are
inspired maybe to play this for life
my first saw this game I was like really
really confused and this was actually
very recent at the pan-american
championships the collegiate
championships in December it was a final
round and I was a top board or the top
team match the Webster B team which is
my high school was playing the UT Dallas
team and it was for first place
and on board for it was mine well voice
for Webster against on hello I realist
Lopez for you to Dallas and hoist one in
14 moves with black so we'll put the
board
and I didn't see the game I saw the
result first and I just didn't
understand how like white could lose in
14 moves the guy's a GM but we'll see
so II 4g5 might see three now mine well
likes to like almost always screen
cathode his King side bishop so he plays
g6 and Lopes actually played the line
which I had recommended before with d4
and they went into kind of the line I
talked briefly about pawn take before
Queen take p4 906 I said earlier that
black has to be careful in this line but
apparently after seeing this game white
also has to be careful really just
especially at the higher levels you have
to really know your opening preparation
so this should be Phi was played the
idea with Bishop e5 is that if knight c6
white just wants to take it and in the
meantime white is preparing to play e5
so black can't really play slowly here
black has to do something
plays a6 probably the best move for
black and here I actually didn't like
the move that Lopez played I actually
have preparation here and the move I
have prepared to d5 which leads to a
really complex position where sometimes
the bishop gets changed for the Knights
and there's some law in computer
analysis but I think it's White's best
try what Lopez played was Queen 1/4
which is also interesting keeping the
pin on a file so the bishop can't be
taken but mom well played a really
resourceful move here and I really like
the simple idea behind this move
very simply b6 wants to develop the
bishop with kind of multiple attacks and
the bishop comes to b7 it will defend
the rook attack the bishop and also
tacky fourth law so very simple but kind
of dangerous idea so why play d5
and Hoyos plays Bishop e7 anyway because
the threats are stronger both attacking
bishop and attacking g2 so question for
you guys what move defends a bishop and
defends the g2 pond yeah
Bishop f1 learning from been Feingold
always played Bishop F 1 this is f 1 is
probably the best move here but it's
sort of in all we move to play your
bishop just developed to d5 and now
basically have to set the board back to
closer to the starting position but
there wasn't really anything else white
could do and from this point forward a
black just played pretty natural moves
and then white kind of self destructed
so then I take sighs Bishop safety 5
Bishop e3 simple moves developed
queenside castle not recommended this is
kind of like walking into a volcano
trying to find shelter bad things are
going to happen b5 the problem is black
is very well equipped to attack on the
Kings side or on the queenside site
because the bishops coming to g7 the
bishop and night already has some scope
on the Queen side Queens coming to a5
and the majority of whites pieces are
undeveloped on the King side and most
accurate move Bishop take a 2 sometimes
it's bad to go pawn driving like this
but in this case it's exploiting kind of
the safety of the black king and the
follow-up after b3 to simply Queen egg 5
and Mike's position is collapsing very
quickly a 6 was played I don't know what
this was maybe a desperate attempt to
trend some Queen take f7 but black just
took and light resigned here may be
premature resignation but blacks up two
pawns has a very very good attack black
is ready just to play Bishop g7 rook c8
and there's no way like surviving this
the computer says like minus 6 here in
favor of black so somewhat inspirational
to see a GM go down in 14 moves as light
but that's why knowing you're opening
preparation can be important any
questions people end it there hope you
guys can join us Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]